desde arriba parece algo de ciencia
ficción pero este laboratorio se utiliza
para simular lo que algún día podría ser
una realidad para la humanidad entre las
estrellas a finales de abril
investigadores de la Universidad de
Arizona pasaron una semana
experimentando lo que es vivir en la
superficie lunar o marciana al cerrar
las compuertas la tripulación quedó
aislada y sin comunicación con el mundo
exterior su hogar esta cápsula conocida
como Sam es uno de los pocos lugares de
la tierra completamente presurizados
solo superado por la estación submarina
de la Nasa en Florida su Estancia les
hizo ocupar el mismo espacio estrecho y
realizar investigaciones
Así que aquí está la tripulación y aquí
es donde vamos a pasar una cantidad
considerable de tiempo haciendo las
actividades de la vida diaria tenemos
una dieta esencialmente vegetariana por
lo que hemos liofilizado o deshidratado
los alimentos el objetivo no es simular
que estamos en Marte sino llevar a cabo
proyectos de investigación aprender Cómo
funciona la dinámica de la tripulación
Cómo realizar estudios sobre la calidad
del agua y del aire
la distribución de la cápsula es muy
similar a la de los astronautas que
vivirán en sus primeras misiones lunares
y marcianas además de un módulo técnico
hay un invernadero donde pueden cultivar
plantas y hortalizas el objetivo es
pasar de los métodos mecánicos de
producción de aire respirable a métodos
en los que básicamente las plantas y las
personas trabajen juntas para crear aire
respirable para ambos el especialista en
sistemas de la misión es ciego un
ejemplo de cómo los perfiles de los
astronautas son cada vez más diversos
capacidades diferentes entre las
tripulaciones del futuro las personas
con discapacidad tienen algo que decir
desde su condición sobre cómo trabajar y
vivir en entornos difíciles algunos de
los astronautas que perdieron la visión
en caminatas espaciales debido a la
acumulación de fluidos o a una fuga Cómo
se puede conformar un equipo con alguien
así y rescatarlo
a largo plazo el director del proyecto
quiere prolongar las misiones durante
varios meses Pero es cauteloso respecto
a las limitaciones desde la guerra de
las Galaxias hasta Star trek y todo lo
demás nos hemos acostumbrado a lo fácil
que parece todo podemos pasar de una
nave espacial a otra a través de una
esclusa de aire sin fisuras podemos
salir de una nave espacial hacia un
planeta y Aparentemente todos los
planetas tienen aire respirable no es
así en el mundo real es muy difícil la
NASA prevé volver a la luna en unos años
y dar nuestros primeros pasos en Marte a
finales de la década de 2030 puede que
esto sea demasiado lento para
multimillonarios como elon musk que
quiere que su empresa spacex lleve un
millón de colonos a Marte en 2050 junto
con ciudades enteras con cúpulas en la
superficie del planeta rojo
el prototipo de estas colonias marcianas
ya existe aquí en Arizona
llamada biosfera 2 su objetivo es
replicar los ecosistemas de la tierra
aquí tenemos una selva tropical
justo al otro lado de esta puerta
tenemos un entorno completamente
diferente
y su vegetación
manglares sabanas tropicales y muchos
otros
en 1991 8 hombres y mujeres se
encerraron en esta tierra simulada
durante dos años
su experimento
mostró los límites del modelo
los recursos y la moral se agotaron
antes de lo esperado
no sabía calculado que los microbios
presentes en el suelo de las plantas
consumen menos oxígeno
el nivel de oxígeno disminuyó tanto que
el equipo tuvo que ponerle del exterior
en cuanto a la agricultura aunque las
plantas crecieran muy bien Esto no es
suficiente para 8 personas
en la actualidad la biosfera 2 está aquí
en la tierra los científicos la estudian
para comprender mejor el calentamiento
global los expertos están de acuerdo en
que entornos como este serán cruciales
para vivir en la superficie marciana
pero prevén que no será posible hasta
dentro de 150 años como mínimo